yesterday the Prime Minister failed to
put the matter to rest so today it fell
to the man himself his chief adviser
Dominic Cummins to explain why he left
London to stay in Durham at the peak of
the lockdown sorry I'm late
this the only apology as he sat out his
version of events in the gardens of
Downing Street I thought there was a
distinct probability that I had already
caught the disease I had a few
conflicting thoughts in my mind first I
was worried that if my wife and I were
both seriously ill possibly hospitalized
there was nobody in London that we could
reasonably ask to look after our child
and exposed themselves to kovat I
thought the best thing to do with all
the circumstances was to drive to an
isolated cottage on my father's farm I
thought that they could stay there for a
few weeks I could go back to work help
colleagues and everybody including the
general public would be safe I did not
ask the Prime Minister about this
decision he also confirmed that he did
take a trip to local beauty spot Barnard
Castle to check his eyesight was good
enough to drive rather than taking in
the sights we agreed that we should go
for a short drive to see if I could
drive safely we drove for roughly half
an hour and ended up on the outskirts of
Barney Castle town we walked about 10 to
15 metres from the car
to the river bank nearby we sat there
for about 15 minutes no offer of
resignation he doesn't think he's done
anything wrong I believe that all the
circumstances I behave reasonably and
legally I can understand that some
people will argue that I should have
stayed at my home in London throughout I
understand these views I know the
intense hardship and sacrifice that the
entire countries had to go through
however I respectfully disagree I
thought and I think today that the rules
including those regarding small children
and extreme circumstances allowed me to
exercise my judgement about the
situation I found myself in I accept of
course that there was room for
reasonable disagreement about this I
know that millions have endured awful
hardship including personal tragedies
over the past few months and people are
suffering every day and I know the
British people hate the idea of
unfairness a many angry and upset about
his conduct ordinary families have put
up with all kinds of risk
actions and hardships people not go into
funerals people not even going into
hospital when their kids have been
having cancer treatment why are you so
different I don't think I'm so different
and I don't think there's one rule for
me and one rule for other people I
looked at their and I knew what the
guidance was it talks about exceptional
circumstances with with small children
this isn't damage the Prime Minister it
has undermined your policy and it's
undermined public confidence in the
government how can you even countenance
at the moment staying on and not
resigning there is understandable anger
but a lot of that anger is based on
reports in the media that have not been
true and it's extremely regrettable but
you didn't think that you ought to check
with the Prime Minister knowing how that
might look how could you not even chat
with your boss that's a very reasonable
question and and I think a lot a lot of
people would say though that I ought to
have called the Prime Minister about it
we all had a million things on our
plates we were trying to do lots of
things I have to get on with things I
have to make make decisions and
sometimes I make do the right thing as
soon as I make mistakes in retrospect
you wish you chat with him fast I don't
know is there is there is it's the
honest truth about that particular thing
maybe I should have done and I made that
judgment in a very short period of time
in very extreme circumstances and as I
said I'd be I thought at the time was
the right thing to do the Prime Minister
standing by his mom but acknowledging
not everyone feels the way he does I do
regret the confusion and the anger and
the pain that people feel and that's why
I really did want people to understand
exactly what had happened
I tried yesterday to to explain my
version of what I heard from from
Dominic Cummings but you know obviously
I couldn't go into it in all the detail
and so that's why we had the the
statement and the the very extensive
questions that we did today your own
scientific advisers have
said by backing him you're undermining
your government's key public health
message at a time of crisis are you
compromising the government's response
to this pandemic because you can't cope
in number 10
without mr. Cummings the only reason
that were able to get this disease under
control
is because people have obeyed the
guidelines I do not believe that anybody
in number 10 has done anything to
undermine our our messaging often seen
but rarely heard but this long bank
holiday weekend people have talked about
little else
an anonymous aide has become a national
conversation mr. Cummings will hope he
did enough today to keep his job but
people are angry even if he does stay
the damage for Boris Johnson is already
done his People's Government has lost
many of its followers
Beth Rigby Sky News Westminster